después de alcanzar máximos históricos
del mes pasado los números de casos de
comida en francia comienzan a moverse en
la dirección opuesta se registró un
promedio de 322 mil infecciones en los
últimos siete días en comparación con
más de 360.000 la semana anterior una
señal alentadora dice el gobierno a
pesar de que el número de pacientes en
hospitales sigue siendo alto la
disminución de nuevos positivos da paso
al inicio de una nueva relajación en dos
etapas de las restricciones restantes a
diferencia de algunos países europeos
que introdujeron bloqueos y toques de
queda durante la navidad cuando
aumentaron los casos de kobe 19 francia
ha dependido en gran medida de la
vacunación para frenar la propagación
del virus se necesita el recientemente
aprobado paseo vacunal para acceder a
todo desde bares y restaurantes lugares
culturales hasta el transporte público
de larga distancia desde este miércoles
las mascarillas ya no son obligatorias
al aire libre se eliminan los límites de
aforo para conciertos y eventos
deportivos y ya no es obligatorio
trabajar desde casa tres días a la
semana
dos semanas los clubes nocturnos
reabrirán los conciertos podrán volver a
realizarse en los cafés y bares ya no
estarán limitados solo el servicio a la
mesa los clientes también podrán comer
en cines estadios y en el transporte
público sin embargo otras medidas
permanecerán vigentes hasta nuevo aviso
como el pase de vacuna y el uso de
mascarillas en espacios públicos
cerrados